[Musik]
tagungspräsident lieber bernd althusmann
liebe freundinnen und freunde meine
damen und herren
vor knapp einem jahr
haben wir die
bundestagswahl verloren
heute im september
2022 sind wir zurück wir sind zurück auf
platz eins unter den deutschen parteien
die christlich demokratische union
wir sind zurück auf platz 1 in den
deutschen parteien weil wir dafür in
diesem jahr hart gearbeitet habe ich
will mich an dieser stelle herzlich
bedanken dass uns dies gemeinsam
gelungen ist präsidium und
bundesvorstand der cdu die neu gewählt
worden sind im januar kam ein gutes
miteinander gefunden eine
vertrauensvolle vertrauliche arbeit im
führungsgremium unserer partei und ich
will stellvertretenden für alle die
dabei sind unser generalsekretär mario
czaja der arbeiten freundschaftlich und
kollegial in diesem ihrem
führungsgremium zusammen
wir haben
wir haben die streitereien von cdu und
csu hinter uns gelassen
markus söder und ich haben uns im januar
getroffen wir haben wir das letzte jahr
gesprochen und wir haben uns gegenseitig
fest in die hand versprochen
2021 wird sich nicht wiederholen
und ich freue mich sehr darüber dass
markus söder morgen zu unserem parteitag
kommen wird ich werde auf dem csu
parteitag gehen und wir werden eine neue
gemeinsamkeit von cdu und csu in
deutschland zeigen und zeigen dass wir
gemeinsam stark sind und gemeinsam die
stärkste politische kraft in diesem
lande sind wir haben eine gute
zusammenarbeit in der bundestagsfraktion
liebe freundinnen und freunde und ich
will auch ausdrücklich sagen mit dem
landesgruppenvorsitzenden alexander
dobrindt der heute nachmittag bei uns
sein wird nach meinem empfinden und ich
kenne diese fraktion ja nun schon seit
einigen jahren ganz gut wir haben selten
ein solches einvernehmen ein solches
vertrauen ein solches freundschaftliches
zusammen wirken an der spitze der
bundestagsfraktion gehabt und auch das
ist ein teil unseres erfolges dass wir
als oppositions fraktionen im deutschen
bundestag zusammen halten und unsere
arbeit gemeinsam machen im deutschen
bundestag
und last but not least sie wissen ich
komme aus dem europäischen parlament
auch die deutsche gruppe im europäischen
parlament beziehen wir in unserer arbeit
daniel caspary vielen dank und den
kolleginnen und kollegen im
europaparlament auch ihr seid ein teil
unserer gemeinsamen arbeit von cdu und
csu
ja liebe freunde
und das sind die erfolgs voraussetzungen
dafür dass man wahlen gewinnen kann
tagungspräsident hat es bereits gesagt
haben einen sensationellen wahlerfolg am
8 mai 2022 in schleswig-holstein erzielt
mit daniel günther als wiedergewählte
ministerpräsidenten daniel herzlichen
glückwunsch noch einmal von dieser
stelle aus herzlichen dank für den
großen erfolg
denn hier im norden erzielt hat
und das war wichtig
denn eine woche später am 15 mai
nordrhein westfalen gerade 200 tage im
amt hendrik wüst am tag vor der wahl
hieß es kopf an kopf und am abend des
wahltages am abend des vortages
abend des wahltages waren es neun
prozentpunkte vorsprung vor den
sozialdemokraten die dieses land einmal
als ihrer herzkammer bezeichnet haben
ich kann nur sagen herzinfarkt bei den
sozialdemokraten in nordrhein-westfalen
und dann
liebe freundinnen freunde nicht mit
einer wahl sondern mit einem
reibungslosen übergang boris rhein in
hessen neuer ministerpräsident fünf
stimmen mehr fünf stimmen mehr als die
koalition dort stimmen hat im landtag
die werbefreien herzlich willkommen
herzlich willkommen in dieser funktion
auch in der führungsmannschaft der cdu
deutschlands wir freuen uns auf gute
zusammenarbeit und ich füge hinzu wir
sagen an dieser stelle ein besonders
herzliches wort des dankes an unseren
freund volker bouffier liebe erfolg hat
jahrzehnte jahrzehnte arbeit in der
landespolitik in der bundespolitik einer
unserer erfolgreichsten
ministerpräsidenten ein treuer freund
und wegbegleiter herzlichen dank auch
von mir persönlich für deine arbeit für
deine freundschaft und für deine hilfe
die wir in dieser partei immer wieder
erfahren haben
liebe freundinnen und freunde wenn wir
es in den nächsten tagen und wochen
richtig machen dann werden wir dieses
jahr abschliessen mit einem weiteren
großen erfolg
das datum ist schon mehrfach genannt
worden am neunten oktober sind die
landtagswahlen hier in niedersachsen
richtig machen heißt dass sie auf diesem
parteitag kluge entscheidungen treffen
dass wir die richtigen prioritäten
setzen uns natürlich mit uns selbst
beschäftigen aber noch viel mehr mit den
menschen draußen mit den unternehmen in
deutschland mit der krise die dieses
land zu bestehen hat mit unseren
antworten wenn wir das richtig machen
wenn von diesem parteitag aus das
richtige signal nach niedersachsen und
darüber hinaus ausgeht dann haben wir
größte chancen dass am 19 oktober der
nächste ministerpräsident des landes
niedersachsen bernd althusmann heißt das
wollen wir gemeinsam erreichen
und so könnte dieses jahr 2022 eines der
erfolgreichsten jahre in unserer
parteiengeschichte werden meine damen
und herren liebe freundinnen und freunde
einer partei die jetzt über 70 jahre alt
ist ich gehöre dieser partei seit 50
jahren an ich bin als schüler und
vorsitzende der jungen union in meiner
heimatstadt brilon unter 72 in die cdu
eingetreten auf dem höhepunkt der
auseinandersetzung um die sogenannten
ostverträge nicht hat damals überzeugt
und begeistert dass die cdu in dieser
auseinandersetzung die einzige partei
war die ohne wenn und aber am
wiedervereinigungs gebot unseres
grundgesetzes für die deutsche einheit
festgehalten hat deshalb bin ich in die
cdu eingetreten im jahr 1972
ich habe etwas in erinnerung
ich habe etwas in erinnerung liebe
freundinnen und freunde damals war die
cdu auch in der opposition aber aus der
opposition heraus kann man etwas
erreichen
die cdu ist nach karlsruhe gegangen mit
der bayerischen staatsregierung zusammen
und hat gegen den grundlagenvertrag mit
der ddr geklagt das ergebnis war dass
die deutsche bundesregierung damals
unter willy brandt eine erklärung
aufnehmen musste zur deutschen einheit
und dieser vertrag nur in kraft treten
konnte mit dieser erklärung zur
deutschen einheit die die cdu csu
durchgesetzt hat aus der opposition
heraus opposition kann etwas bewirken
das haben wir 1972 schon einmal gezeigt
ich war
zehn jahre später
junger student in bonn bei den grössten
demonstrationen die es damals gegen die
nato nachrüstung gegeben hat ein
beschluss an der die regierung von
helmut schmidt gescheitert ist und die
erst helmut kohl anschließend
durchsetzen konnte liebe freundinnen und
freunde damals schon einmal gegen den
protest der öffentlichkeit gegen
diejenigen die auf die straße gegangen
sind die cdu hat kurs gehalten und wenn
sie damals nicht kurs gehalten hätte
wären die voraussetzungen für die
deutsche einheit nicht mehr erfüllt
gewesen auch das hat mich tief geprägt
in meiner zeit als student und
referendar damals wie helmut kohl diesen
protest in deutschland begegnet ist
und dann
erinnere ich nicht an den vierten mai
1985 das war ein samstag ich war am tag
zuvor gerade als junger richter am
amtsgericht in saarbrücken vereidigt
worden am vierten mai hielt richard von
weizsäcker unser damaliger
bundespräsident seine rede zum
vierzigsten jahrestag des endes des
zweiten weltkrieges eine rede die auf
der ganzen welt beachtung gefunden hat
als die rede schlechthin zu diesem tag
des gedenkens an das ende des zweiten
weltkrieges und aus dieser rede ist mir
ein satz in erinnerung geblieben an
diesem samstagmorgen der lautete bei uns
so hat er gesagt ist eine neue
generation in die politische an
verantwortung hineingewachsen die jungen
so hat er gesagt sind nicht
verantwortlich für das was damals
geschah aber sie sind verantwortlich für
das was in der geschichte
daraus wird dieser satz hat sich mir
eingeprägt und ich hätte mir niemals
vorstellen können dass es einen
deutschen bundeskanzler nach diesem satz
noch einmal geben würde der im
bundeskanzleramt
schweigend hinnimmt dass dort von
demjenigen der sich präsident der
autonomiebehörde der palästinenser nennt
übelste vorwürfe gegen den staat israel
erhoben werden der blanke antisemitismus
dort zum ausdruck gebracht wird und der
deutsche bundeskanzler schweigt und ihm
anschließend noch die hand reiche ich
hätte es mir niemals vorstellen
dass so etwas passiert
olaf scholz wird sich möglicherweise an
diese begegnung heute schon nicht mehr
erinnern aber
die weltgemeinschaft
aber die weltgemeinschaft
die weltgemeinschaft hat diese bilder
aus dem deutschen bundeskanzleramt
gesehen und wird sie in erinnerung
behalten und liebe freundinnen freunde
stellen wir uns noch einmal einen kurzen
augenblick vor es wäre nicht olaf scholz
claudia roth dem kanzleramt diese frau
die ständig mit 70 dezibel durch die
republik reist sondern angela merkel und
monika grütters und es hätte diese
vorgänge um die documenta in kassel
gegeben was in diesem lande los wäre ich
sage antisemitismus wird nicht dadurch
besser dass er von links kommt von
beiden seiten aus müssen wir uns in
diesem lande dagegen wehren was da hier
gerade passiert und klarstellen dass
dies auf null toleranz stößt in
deutschland
und ich füge hinzu
dieses erbe ist genau der grund warum es
niemals
und an keiner stelle im bund nicht in
den ländern nicht in europa nicht
niemals eine zusammenarbeit von der cdu
und der csu mit der afc in diesem lande
geben wird niemals würde seine
zusammenarbeit mit dieser partei geben
und dann
bin ich 1989 als einer der beiden
jüngsten deutschen abgeordneten in das
europäische parlament gewählt worden
diese zeit hat mich sehr geprägt die
bestimmt bis heute mein politisches
denken mein politisches handeln und
meine politischen erfahrungen sie sind
die größten in dieser zeit gewesen ich
weiß wie kompliziert diese europäische
union ist aber ich weiß auch ohne europa
und unsere partner in der europäischen
union wäre es niemals möglich gewesen
einen deutschen bundeskanzler helmut
kohl zu haben der die deutsche einheit
im jahre 1990 ein jahr später
verwirklicht ich habe die europäische
einheit und die deutsche einheit aus der
perspektive des europäischen parlaments
miterlebt und ich weiß welchen schatz
welchen wert es hat dass wir freunde und
partner in europa haben dürfen wir nicht
leichtfertig aufs spiel setzen diese
freundschaft mit europa
[Applaus]
und die borussia fand allein darf ich
das hier in dieser offenheit sagen
europa ist gefordert wie wahrscheinlich
schon lange nicht mehr
konzentration auf das wesentliche
gemeinsame außen und sicherheitspolitik
gemeinsame wirtschaftspolitik gemeinsame
finanzpolitik gemeinde chrisam
krisenbewältigung aber es kann nicht
sein dass dieser apparat in brüssel
arbeitet und arbeitet und arbeitet und
produziert und produziert und eine
richtlinie eine verordnung nach der
anderen produziert als ob da nie
irgendwas gewesen wäre jetzt heißt es
auch für europa stoppt mit dieser
regulierung und überregulierung und
konzentration auf krisenbewältigung in
der europäischen union und diesen
auftrag diesen auftrag möchte ich
unseren europaabgeordneten und auch der
kommission gerne mit auf den weg geben
europa
liebe freundinnen und freunde wird seine
legitimation verlieren wenn es uns nicht
gelingt in dieser herausfordernden zeit
eine gemeinsame und geschlossene antwort
der europäer zu geben und das schätzen
wir nicht was auf der welt passiert
es ist nicht nur eine zeitenwende
es ist ein epochenbruch den wir erleben
dagegen alte gewissheiten zum teufel und
neue realitäten entstehen und deshalb
nehmen wir unsere arbeit auch im
deutschen bundestag so sehr ernst ja wir
sind opposition im deutschen bundestag
aber opposition ist nicht mist nein
opposition ist konstitutiver bestandteil
der politischen ordnung der
bundesrepublik deutschland einer
demokratie ohne opposition wäre die
demokratie keine demokratie und deswegen
spielen wir auf gleicher augenhöhe mit
der bundesregierung diese aufgabe füllen
diese aufgabe im deutschen bundestag aus
und dass wir dabei wirkungstreffer
erzielen können das konnten sie in
dieser woche zum wiederholten male
erleben das machen wir weiter so und das
werden wir auch im deutschen bundestag
gemeinsam weiter auf den weg bringen
wir sind bereit mit der bundesregierung
zusammenzuarbeiten so weit es möglich
ist aber wir werden dieser
bundesregierung auch entgegentreten und
andere antworten geben soweit es nötig
ist
wir sind gerade in der krise bereit und
haben es bewiesen mit der
bundesregierung zusammenzuarbeiten
wir haben ein großes paket geschnürt für
die bundeswehr wir haben es getan und
lassen sie mich das hier ganz offen
sagen weil auch wir mitverantwortung
tragen dafür dass die bundeswehr nicht
in dem zustand ist indem sie sein sollte
auch deshalb haben wir so bestimmt für
100 milliarden euro und das sind neue
schulden eine änderung des grundgesetzes
und eine zusätzliche belastung der
jungen generation aber wir stehen dazu
weil wir für unsere sicherheit und für
unsere freiheit etwas tun müssen mehr
tun müssen als in den letzten jahren
wir haben mit den parteien der ampel
regierung am 28 april eine gemeinsame
entschließung in den deutschen bundestag
eingebracht und mit ganz großer mehrheit
beschlossen über humanitäre hilfe
finanzielle hilfe und auch militärische
hilfe für die ukraine
ja auch mit schweren waffen die wir an
die ukraine liefern müssen
es fällt uns vielleicht schwer zu
akzeptieren und ich weiß dass auch in
unserer partei darüber
diskutiert wird aber liebe freundinnen
und freunde darf ich noch einmal einen
einzigen satz vorlesen aus dem interview
dass herfried münkler vor drei wochen
gegeben hat und das sehr eindringlich
daran erinnert hat dass man frieden
nicht nur mit gutem zureden und
gesprächsangeboten erreichen kann der
weg an den verhandlungstisch
so sagt er führt einzig über
militärische erfolge der ukraine die
russland die aussicht auf den großen
sieg nehmen ende des zitats ja das ist
die bittere wahrheit
das ist die bittere
als
und deswegen sprechen wir uns dafür aus
dass sie etwas tun dass wir mehr tun als
sie im augenblick tatsächlich tun und
ich will es hier sehr deutlich sagen mit
fdp und grünen zusammen hätte ich eine
exportgenehmigung für 100 marder panzer
an die ukraine erteilt damit klar ist
dass wir alles tun was in unseren
möglichkeiten steht um diesem land zu
helfen
und es geht
es geht wie wir alle wissen nicht nur in
anführungsstrichen um dieses land so
haben wir es doch alle gesagt auch der
bundeskanzler dieser angriff auf die
ukraine ist nicht nur ein angriff auf
die territoriale integrität des
zweitgrößten nach territorium
zweitgrößten landes europas es ist ein
angriff auf die politische
friedensordnung der nachkriegszeit es
ist ein angriff auf unsere freiheit und
liebe freundinnen und freunde vielleicht
fehlt uns mittlerweile an der einen oder
anderen stelle das bewusstsein für die
richtigen prioritäten lassen sie mich
mit kaya kallas sagen der
ministerpräsidentin von estland die vor
einigen tagen in einem interview in
einer deutschen zeitung gesagt hat
energiepreise mögen steigen aber
freiheit ist unbezahlbar ja das muss
auch unser board aus deutschland sein
freiheit ist unbezahlbar
und ich erinnere nicht aus gründen
historische reminiszenzen an diese jahre
der gründungsgeschichte unseres landes
und der parteiengeschichte der cdu
deutschlands erinnere insbesondere an
das jahr 1982 war uns 40 jahre später
2022 möglicherweise eine ähnliche
bewährungsprobe bevor steht wie vor 40
jahren
dass wir nämlich antworten geben müssen
die unbequem sind die auch dem einen
oder anderen nicht gefallen mögen aber
liebe freundinnen und freunde für uns
kommt nicht erst das fressen und dann
die moral sondern wir haben einen klaren
kompass die freiheit die demokratie die
offenheit die liberalität unserer
gesellschaft das sind die höchsten güter
und dafür müssen wir bereit sein
notfalls auch einen preis zu bezahlen ja
die cdu deutschlands ist es die an
dieser stelle mehr gefragt ist als alle
anderen parteien in unserem lande
und an alle diejenigen
die immer noch zweifeln an alle
diejenigen die immer noch zweifeln
möchte ich einen einzigen satz nur
richten
wenn russland
die waffen schweigen lässt ist der krieg
zu ende
wenn die ukraine die waffen niederlegt
ist
die territoriale integrität und die
existenz dieses landes am ende das ist
der unterschied auf denen wir hinweisen
müssen das ist der unterschied um den es
in dieser auseinandersetzung geht
klarheit
notfalls hätte
konsequenz in dem was man tut und
jederzeit die gesprächsbereitschaft
offen zu halten auch mit russland können
und dürfen nur die einzigen antworten
seien die aus der staatengemeinschaft
des westens kommt der europäischen union
der nato all derer die in diesem
konflikt involviert sind und helfen
wollen so wie wir das alle gemeinsam tun
wollen
liebe freunde freunde dieser parteitag
steht unter dem motto mit klarem kurs
mehr sicherheit für deutschland wir
meinen mit mir mehr sicherheit nicht nur
die innere sicherheit und die äußere
sicherheit unseres landes wir sprechen
natürlich auch über
versorgungssicherheit für deutschland
wir haben uns in diesem land zu abhängig
gemacht von
russischem gas ich sage wir das war ein
fehler das war eine große politische
dummheit es war vielleicht auch ein
gehöriges maß an naivität und das müssen
wir jetzt korrigieren
daran waren wir auch beteiligt aber ich
werde es nicht zulassen dass der
eindruck erweckt wird in deutschland
dass dies allein 16 jahre cdu und csu
gewesen sind 20 von 24 der letzten jahre
haben sozialdemokraten in deutschland
mit regiert sie tragen mindestens
genauso dieselbe verantwortung für diese
dummheit und für diese naivität und für
diese fehler die wir in deutschland
gemacht haben und anders als die
sozialdemokraten hat es bei uns nie eine
solche politische korruption gegeben wie
bei der spd und das zentrum das zentrum
das zentrum
das zentrum dieser abgrundtiefen
korruption ist nicht berlin sondern ist
hier in hannover meine damen und herren
liebe freundinnen und freunde hier in
hannover sitzt das netzwerk das bis
heute offensichtlich funktioniert und
das müssen wir natürlich auch zur
sprache bringen wenn es um die fehler
der vergangenheit geht aber jetzt
schauen wir natürlich richtigerweise
auch nach vorn wir schauen nach vorn um
diese abhängigkeit zu reduzieren und
durch andere lieferquellen zu
erschließen
aber dies ist doch noch nicht die stunde
für kleine helden und große abenteuer
liebe freundin freunde kleine helden
große
abenteuer ist der titel eines
kinderbuchs von robert habeck
damit hier kein zweifel entsteht
kinderbücher sind eine wunderbare sache
und philosophie ist eine fantastische
wissenschaft
aber nur mit kinderbüchern und
philosophie kann man doch die probleme
unseres landes nicht lösen
meine damen und herren als ob er
als ob er eine vorahnung als ob er eine
vorahnung gehabt hätte auf das was auf
ihn möglicherweise mal zukunft schreibt
er in diesem buch wörtlich die kleine
susanne entdeckt mit ihrer freundin die
geheimnisse der zeit und emily erfährt
aus erster hand wie aufgrund eines
nächtlichen
stromausfalls sein kann meine damen und
herren ja so schreibt robert habeck aber
wir haben hier nicht wunderland in
deutschland wir sind nicht bullerbü wir
sind die viertgrößte industrienationen
der welt die sich nicht leisten kann ein
traineeprogramm für
bundeswirtschaftsminister aufzusetzen
sondern wir brauchen hier menschen in
den ämtern die was verstehen von aufgabe
die sie da wahrnehmen
und wenn der trainer merkt dass die
mannschaftsaufstellungen nicht optimal
ist da muss er eingreifen und dann muss
notfalls die zuständigkeiten ins
bundeskanzleramt holen ich habe den
vorschlag am mittwoch gemacht wiederhole
ihn hier mindestens
einen energie sicherheitsrat im
kanzleramt mit experten von außen besser
noch einen nationalen sicherheitsrat in
deutschland eingerichtet nach dem
vorbild vieler anderer westlicher länder
die die es längst tun und nicht zulassen
dass da auf zweiter und dritter ebene
dilettiert wird sondern dass
professionell gearbeitet wird und auf
eine solche herausforderung richtig
reagiert wird mehr können wir doch im
augenblick von dieser bundesregierung
nicht erwarten als dass sie das tut und
wir sind sogar bereit ihr dabei zu
helfen wenn sie uns fragt aber sie steht
in der verantwortung diese aufgabe jetzt
wahrzunehmen und wir sagen
wir sagen auf einen solchen angebots
schock und das ist ja einen
angebotsschock dann plötzlich das gas
aus bleibt in diesem umfang dann muss
man mit einer ausweitung des angebots
antworten und ausweitung des angebotes
kann doch nur heißen in dem augenblick
in dem wir jetzt sind volle kraft voraus
mit allem was uns zur verfügung steht
braunkohle steinkohle
selbstverständlich jede form der
regenerativen energien biomasse wind und
sonne und natürlich auch kernenergie wo
ist denn eigentlich das problem dass wir
das in deutschland nicht hinbekommen
was haben wir denn da in den letzten
tagen seit letzten montag erlebt und
gehört das ist doch unfassbar was da
vorgetragen wird dies gestammelt dann
anschließend in den fernsehnachrichten
meine damen und herren wie ich fordere
von dieser stelle den bundeskanzler auf
stunden sie dieses rot grün gelben
narrenschiff auf diesem kurs auf den sie
sind und korrigieren sie diesen kurs so
schnell wie möglich damit unser land
nicht in eine ernsthafte
wirtschaftskrise abstürzt stoppten sie
das
und werden besorgte
zeitgenossen fragen ja aber wie geht
denn das mit der umwelt weiter
wie geht denn das mit unseren zielen
klimaneutralität zu verwirklichen bis
meine damen und herren 2 anton darauf
die erste bis zum jahr 2020
haben wir in deutschland die klimaziele
erreicht
seit 1990 hat sich die
wirtschaftsleistung unseres landes
verdoppelt
und die co2 emissionen um 40 prozent
reduziert bis zum jahr 2020 und sie
wissen wer in dieser zeit regiert hat es
war ein unions geführte
bundesregierungen seit 2005 in der
verantwortung auch für diese schwierige
aufgabe
klimaneutralität zu erreichen 40 prozent
das ist die gute nachricht
die etwas weniger gute nachricht ist
jetzt wirds schwierig und unter den
bedingungen der krise unter den
bedingungen dass wir fossile brennstoffe
wieder nutzen müssen nicht mehr möglich
jedenfalls nicht so allein mit
vermeidung von co2 so wie wir uns das
bisher vorgenommen haben wird es sicher
nicht gehen und trotzdem müssen wir die
ziele erreichen trotzdem müssen wir bis
zum jahr 2045 spätestens klimaneutral
werden wie machen wir das wir haben in
diesem leitantrag der ihnen als
initiativantrag des bundesvorstandes
vorliegt dazu ein kapitel geschrieben
und wir sagen auch denjenigen die sich
zu recht um die umwelt sorgen und die
uns zu recht fragen
welche antworten habt ihr denn wenn es
sich allein mit vermeidung nicht
erreichen ist dann müssen wir
technologien einsetzen dann müssen wir
co2 zurückgewinnen dann müssen wir es
trennen von verbrennungsprozessen und
industrieprozessen dann müssen wir es
als rohstoff verstehen und nicht nur als
umweltzerstörung und dann müssen wir
etwas tun was wir schon einmal sehr
erfolgreich getan haben wir müssen an
kreisläufe denken an
wirtschaftskreisläufe an recycling liebe
freundinnen und freunde das waren die
großen umweltpolitischen erfolge der
union verbindet sich mit namen von uns
in unseren regierungen dass wir so etwas
hinbekommen haben warum kriegen wir das
denn dann mit co2 nicht auch hin dann
höre ich den einwand jahr hat das sei ja
alles viel zu teuer als der erste
ottomotor gebaut war der erste diesel
gebaut war die waren so teuer die hat
auch keiner gekauft aber die innovation
war da die erfindung war da es waren
erfindungen aus deutschland was hindert
uns denn jetzt daran genau auf diesem
weg wieder voranzugehen zu sagen den
anspruch an uns selbst zu stellen wir
wollen die modernsten technologien in
deutschland entwickeln zusammen wo immer
möglich mit den europäischen nachbarn
und freunden aber zur not auch allein
wir wollen die modernsten technologien
entwickeln damit wir tatsächlich
klimaneutral werden im jahr 2045
vielleicht so gut dass wir damit wieder
technischer schrittmacher
technologischer schrittmacher auf der
ganzen welt sein können was hindert uns
nicht daran diesen anspruch an uns
selbst zu stellen
zuzugestehen
zuzugestehen das ist so wie bisher
gut ging aber nicht weitergeht und dass
wir in zukunft etwas anderes auf den weg
bringen müssen das könnte eine antwort
von uns sein denn wir müssen heute die
frage beantworten wovon unsere kinder
und enkelkinder in den nächsten zehn
jahren 20 jahren und 30 jahren in
unserem land denn neben sollen von
gleichstellungsbeauftragten allein
werden sie nicht leben können meine
damen und herren wir brauchen
produzierende industrie
wir brauchen produzierende industrie in
deutschland
wir brauchen unternehmen mit
wertschöpfung wir brauchen eine
wettbewerbsfähige industrie
und sind die fragen vdv gestellt sind
und die wir beantworten wollen müssen
nicht allein materielle fragen müssen
auch die frage beantworten in welcher
gesellschaft wir denn leben wollen was
macht uns als land denn aus in dieser
welt die sich so radikal verändert nun
auch da hilft ein blick in unsere
geschichte auch ein blick in unser
grundgesetz wir haben die
freiheitlichste verfassung die jemals
auf deutschem boden existiert hat wir
können unverändert stolz darauf sein ein
solches land zu sein die freiheitlichste
gesellschaft offen liberal frei wie
unsere großeltern sie sich nur haben
erträumen können freiheit in jeder
hinsicht meinungsfreiheit pressefreiheit
wahlfreiheit vereinigungsfreiheit
freiheit unternehmen zu gründen freiheit
den beruf auszuüben eine ausbildung
einzugehen ja selbst die freiheit
einfach nichts zu tun auch diese
freiheit hat unsere gesellschaft aber
diejenigen die sich diese freiheit
nehmen haben nicht den anspruch darauf
dass diese gesellschaft ihnen dann auch
gleichzeitig den lebensunterhalt sichert
geworden und das ist der entscheidende
unter zwischen uns und insbesondere den
sozialdemokraten diese worte die da
immer wieder fallen von grundsicherung
und
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen das sind
nicht unsere vorstellungen von freiheit
und verantwortung
wir gehen von einem menschenbild aus und
dieses menschenbild heißt zunächst
einmal ist jeder für sich persönlich
verantwortlich jeder ist ein individuum
wir gehen nicht vom kollektiv aus wir
denken nicht vom kollektiv aus wir
denken vom einzelnen menschen und wir
sagen dass als christen als
christdemokraten es muss nicht jeder
unseren glauben teilen aber dahinter
steht ein menschenbild und weil es
einmal eine diskussion war will ich an
dieser stelle gleich sagen mit mir als
vorsitzenden wird es daran auch an
unserem namen mit dem c keine
veränderung geben wir bleiben dabei dass
diese szene in unserem namen steht
nicht weil wir
nicht weil wir katholisch oder
evangelisch sind sondern weil wir doch
irgendwo tief in unserem inneren meinen
zu spüren das ist eine höhere instanz
gibt als uns und dass wir auf dieser
welt vielleicht eben doch nur die
vorletzten antworten geben nicht die
letzten aber das wird uns in unserem
ringen und in unserem bemühen nicht
nachlassen
alles zu tun damit wir eine lebenswerte
freiheitliche gesellschaft bleiben meine
damen und herren um es noch deutlicher
zu sagen jeder darf in diesem land leben
wie er will darf lieben wen er will und
darf reden was er will das macht die
freiheit unseres landes aus aber wenn
der oberbürgermeister noch da wäre würde
ich auch in seiner gegenwart gerne sagen
das schließt ein dass zumindest die
öffentlich rechtlichen institutionen und
staatlichen institutionen allgemeine
regeln akzeptieren
universitäten meine damen und herren und
öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk sind
keine sind keine volks
erziehungsanstalten sondern sie haben
einen staatlichen bildungsauftrag
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk hat
einen staatlich bestimmten
informationsauftrag und dann die halten
sie sich bitte und an die regeln die wir
uns alle in diesem land gegeben haben
auch für die verwendung der deutschen
sprache im privatleben können sie machen
und tun und lassen was sie wollen
aber wenn sie einen auftrag aber wenn
sie einen auftrag ausführen der entweder
mit steuermitteln oder mit gebühren die
von allen erhoben werden finanziert wird
dann kann man erwarten dass sie sich an
die allgemein anerkannten regeln in der
nutzung der deutschen sprache der
sprache von goethe und schiller von kant
und hegel einfach an diese regeln halten
ihre freundinnen und freunden und so
machen wir uns jetzt auf den weg der
erneuerung der cdu
dieser parteitag
ist eine etappe ist ein schritt auf
diesem weg
wir werden 2023 eine intensive
diskussion über unsere grundsätze haben
den ersten teil der diskussion führen
wir morgen und ich will an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich dank sagen alle denjenigen
die in der grundsatzprogramm kommission
die arbeit aufgenommen haben das ist
nicht für alle sofort und unmittelbar
ersichtlich
aber da findet eine intensive arbeit
statt in zehn kommissionen ein teil
dieser arbeit bekommen sie morgen
bereits präsentiert und wir diskutieren
morgen darüber
herzlichen dank an alle diejenigen die
da mitwirken und ich nenne
stellvertretend an erster stelle carsten
linnemann serap kühler und mario voigt
die diese arbeit geleistet haben auch
andreas röder der heute bei uns ist wir
führen diese diskussion wir machen es
uns nicht leicht wir machen es uns
schwer weil wir uns selbst vergewissern
wollen wo wir stehen und wo wir hin
wollen in den nächsten jahren aber
wir werden die cdu nicht neu erfinden
wir stehen auf einem festen fundament
wir haben eine grundüberzeugung und
trotzdem sind wir jederzeit bereit
kritisch selbst kritisch zu überprüfen
ob unsere position immer noch die
richtigen sind wir bleiben im besten
sinne des wortes offen wir bleiben
gespannt wir hören zu und wir sind
trotzdem und bleiben eine konservative
eine liberale und eine soziale partei
daran wird sich nichts ändern
liebe freundinnen und freunde in der
diskussion die wir jetzt vor uns haben
und dann gehen wir auf diesem weg in das
jahr 2024 hinein und dann werden wir
einen mehrtägigen großen parteikongress
machen wo wir das grundsatzprogramm
verabschieden wo wir ein europa
wahlprogramm verabschieden wo wir dann
auch neuwahlen für den bundesvorstand
wahlen und neuwahlen für den
bundesvorstand haben werden und wo wir
uns dann auch auf das große wahl jahr
2025 vorbereiten dies ist heute hier ein
erster schritt und ich will zum schluss
noch einmal an sie herzlich appellieren
lassen sie uns gemeinsam verantwortlich
mit dem was uns in diesen beiden tagen
heute und morgen vor nicht umgehen da
schauen sehr viele wählerinnen und
wähler nicht nur unsere mitglieder auf
uns und stellen sich die frage was macht
diese cdu da jetzt wie geht sie mit
diesen großen themen unserer zeit um
welche antworten gibt sie auf der
herausforderungen vor denen die privaten
haushalte die unternehmen stehen einen
umfangreichen vorschlag haben wir ihnen
dazu unterbreitet mit dem leitantrag des
bundesvorstandes aber bitte ordnen wir
es auch richtig ein die beschäftigung
mit uns selbst ist notwendig aber die
beschäftigung mit der lage der menschen
mit der lage der betriebe in deutschland
ist notwendiger als die beschäftigung
mit uns selbst
meine damen und herren
[Musik]
liebe freundinnen und freunde wenn wir
diesen anspruch den wir an uns selbst
stellen einlösen dann ist das was ich zu
beginn gesagt habe dass wir wieder
zurück sind auf platz eins unter den
deutschen parteien nicht nur eine
momentaufnahme
dann wird es wieder das werden was es
über diese vielen jahrzehnte in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland war dann ist die cdu
zusammen mit der csu die bestimmende
politische kraft unseres landes daran
wollen wir gemeinsam arbeiten dazu rufe
ich sie alle auf daran mitzuwirken und
das macht doch auch freude im dienste
unseres so wunderschönen landes der
bundesrepublik deutschland diese arbeit
zu leisten nehmen sie daran teil zeigen
wir diesen führungsanspruch an unsere
mitglieder aber auch und vor allem an
die wählerinnen und wähler in
deutschland ich danke ihnen sehr
[Applaus]
die cdu feiert ihren neu gewählten
vorsitzenden friedrich merz der hier
eine rede gehalten hat die vereinigen
seele der delegierten erreichen sollte
opposition ist mist hat einmal ein
anderer parteilose liste der
sozialdemokraten in jedem fall franz
müntefering gesagt aber friedrich merz
abt dargestellt dass die
oppositionsarbeit auch etwas bewirken
kann und er ist ja auch
fraktionsvorsitzender der cdu csu
die rede war deshalb aber auch
überraschend weil gefühlig merckx auf
das thema auf dass hier alle gewartet
haben gar nicht eingegangen ist nämlich
die frauenquote er hat es noch nichtmals
indirekt angesprochen und für mich meine
damen und herren ist mit der heutigen
rede endgültig aufgeklärt
das verhältnis von friedrich merz zu der
frage
kanzlerkandidatur mit fdp und grünen
hätte ich gemeinsam ein
mandat erlassen dass wir marder panzer
an die ukraine liefern hat er gesagt und
meinte natürlich damit dass er hat
bundeskanzler das nur gemeinsam mit den
beiden anderen partnern machen würde
aber wer friedrich merz schon lange und
gut kennt er hatte an keinen zweifel
natürlich sieht er sich vorne er ist ja
auch der partei und
fraktionsvorsitzender und auch wenn er
die beiden ministerpräsidenten wüste und
günter vorne brat gelobt hat sieht er in
ihnen nicht die jugendliche konkurrenz
sondern traut sich wohl doch zu in zwei
jahren sich selber ganz nach vorne zu
setzen was die kanzlerkandidatur angeht
er hat auch angesprochen nächstes jahr
wird es keinen parteitag geben sondern
20 24 der große programmatische breite
aber bis dahin ist ja noch so viel zeit
viel viel applaus der delegierten ich
möchte nicht wissen wie der ein oder
andere über die frage warum der
vorsitzende nix gesagt zu dieser
kernfrage frauenquote aber das können
wir jetzt mal meine kollegin inge swolek
fragen die glaube ich bei den sachsen
steht